[Music]
let's talk about who got your first
impression rose you said you were
smitten
I mean fresh out of the minivan maybe
ever say limo
I liked that Garrett could be
light-hearted and laugh about the future
about being a dad and having the minivan
one day I hope to be a great dad after
Monday's season premiere of The
Bachelorette bachelor nation was just as
smitten with Garrett as Becca kufran I
was smitten by him but the Nevada native
has found himself at the center of a
controversy for allegedly liking
Instagram posts which mocked transgender
people feminist immigrants and Kirkland
shooting survivors the Instagram
accounts that allegedly belonged to him
was deleted shortly after screenshots of
the posts went viral
now Becca is telling ET she wants her
fans to keep an open mind what do you
say to that is it weird to have one of
your guys the first impression rose guy
in the middle of this controversy
already
I want viewers to be open to everyone
and I want them to go through the season
with me and watch my love story unfold
with all of these men and to be open
because that's how I went into this
journey and so you know people say and
do certain things I've done things in
the past that I'm sure I it wasn't the
best thing how would you address
something like that with any guy really
if you found out something like that we
would have a discussion about it we
would get to the bottom of it and find a
solution I can't fault anyone for what
they believe and you know who's to say
that anything that anyone likes is truly
what they believe and if they just
DoubleTap I can't speak to that because
it's not me but I am a strong woman and
I do believe in certain things but again
that's what's so great about our country
is everyone is entitled to their own
opinions
you